I'm making coffee
I'm making coffee!
Tell them I'm making coffee
Chris is making coffee he wanted me to tell
you
Well there's no one on the air so it's fine
This is Chenzo
God CY you're so wrong and let me tell you
why because that's just why it's so great
blueberries that's why blueberries are so
great because the tasty ones come at you and
explode in your mouth while sometimes you
get some bitter ones and that's like a special
treat it makes the whole experience better.
Bye. Sorry guys my friends were having an
argument what were the best fruits and it's
blueberry and that's it. I don't want to talk
about it.
You guys ready or what dude? I have a White
Claw we're just classing this whole thing
up. Oh god all right hold on. Let me get my-
Guys hold on one second we're just setting
up you know. I honestly think bananas are
better. Oh bananas don't even enter the chat
dude, bananas don't enter the chat. I don't
like any fruit- I don't like any fruit with
casing dude like pineapples and- pineapples
are great but they lose because it's like
oh what's in here and it's just pineapple
not [ __ ] cash they have a spiky [ __ ] thing
like it's [ __ ] But it keeps it fresh. If
anything it's like you're getting a fresh
bite whereas the blueberries are already kind
of sitting out in the air
just like picking up particles and bacteria
and stuff. But that's what all food does anyway
right? I don't know? Yeah. Well what I'm saying
is that the highlight of a banana is that
it's in the casing. The highlight of a banana?
Yeah. If that's that's a highlight- the highlight
should be how it tastes? And it's a really
good food like if I'm really hungry in the
middle of the night it's a good food for that,
good food in the morning, it's healthy. It's
a versatile food you're saying? Versatile,
yeah. You can bring it. Okay I'll give you
that you can bring it somewhere. You can't
like bring a handful of blueberries.
What's up guys welcome to FlexAvenue we're
uh we keep thinking we're gonna do a new game
but we don't because we actually kind of like
this game and to be honest it takes two and
we're the two that it takes so we beat some
bees we beat uh toolbox and we beat uh a vacuum
cleaner so let's see what's next come on down
to FlexAvenue and join us and remember Life
Rips i got the shirt on and the pants dude
sorry watch out for my quads but wow so [ __
] that it was on the left side and i had to
lean over like this but if you want to check
out quads there we go it's all good dude wait
stand up give me a wedgie no no you're gonna
poke my butt no go to the side though your
butt does look good in those lean a little
bit down and these shorts for whatever reason
fit really nicely no i have a back seat dude
yeah i noticed that i have a back i noticed
that i that i uh have a back seat the other
day when i re-watched a little bit of the
twitch and i turned around i had a back seat
johnny's got a back seat dude i got one of
those back seats in the back of a station
wagon where the sometimes you look and there's
just like someone sitting on the back of it
facing the other way yeah that's what you
have what do i have a slide
oh okay you gotta goop it up remember goop
it up honey it up dude sap it up that's what
it is sap it up i like goop though
sap it up and your boy will flame it there
we go
your boy keeps it nice and flamey i definitely
keep it nice and flamey oh okay oh ouchie
honestly are these boss so russian no so like
are these boss?
making my way to the slugs
babe
shooting this sap
dun dun dun had a bat
babe
what
how many white claws have you had
look I need to we need to explode the other
ones dude oh dude unreal man i already i'm
already mad dude i have a limit you know what
I mean
hmm what do you mean
i get angry and I have a limit
of anger?
i have a limit to where i can only get so
far and then i blow my top i blow my lid i
blow my [ __ ] lid and then and then
oh oh god dude come on
he disintegrated
johnny disintegrates
i know dude somebody's like you gotta lead
i know i'm leading dude I know
yeah lead
i'm leading i am trust me i'm leading no
you're a bad leader
i'm not a bad leader it's sexy the way I lead
hehe
okay jump there we go and then just relax
i know i get a little bit you get jumpy and
it's fine yeah but just relax you make the
move and then you relax yeah right so jump
it jump dash jump and then relax right there's
no rush what do we have a meeting we don't
jump dash jump just relax
what what do I
to the glowing thing jump dash jump it's all
good relax relax so you didn't relax enough
but it's fine but you didn't relax enough
okay that could have been trouble right sure
but you didn't relax enough but it's fine
we did it so jump dash jump right on that
thing it's okay you got it and relax no here
we go dude now slide down the
baby good job
come on don't do that wow we're team if you
do that that's [ __ ] that's mutiny
i think that's us with our kids oh cute oh
my god imagine Cal playing soccer how cute
i know i know it's like us
do you see the picture oh that's very cute
yeah
we haven't taken any professional photos of
us yet you me and Cal we haven't done that
we should what
we haven't taken any pictures like family
photos since Cal's been alive we haven't no
oh yeah because of the pandemic yeah we gotta
do that oh no dude look at how many this is
a swarm so we learned stuff too during this
game it's a swarm okay now it's lean back
and relax oh oh oh oh wow that was way way
okay here we go another swarm
oh this is fun
i think you might have spoke too soon sweetheart
i talk like that now died wow babe no but
because i was instructing it's hard to instruct
well they say that those who can't do teach
so no but i can do both okay look we'll cut
that out from the highlight reel here we go
cody get some sap on this swarm come on cody
oh dude look at why would you be looking at
me i mean look at what's going on because
i like seeing your face while you're doing
that's very sweet that's very sweet when you
looked at me i looked at you and i missed
it and i'm pissed off at that
wow
woh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh previously on chris's
life i got a [ __ ] on me and then back to
the game okay now do you understand what you
have to do do you don't do the meme face do
you understand okay so here we go you gotta
do it for real though okay i'm having trouble
it's all good where am i shooting but you
know how i say use looking do that yeah now
now we're going sideways right and that's
bad because we're just
okay that's good
keep doing that and and if we get hit it spins
around so if we get hit stop shooting right
okay now we gotta go this way
keep going there we go we gotta go through
there well what happened did you just replace
your brain
honestly what just happened you you just how
did you do that were you [ __ ] with me no
i honest to god was pressing the wrong button
oh jesus look at the screen look at my screen
what do you think you have to do what are
those
we're live
extra paper sap that up okay no now oh oh
see that's the hit I didn't say anything I
asked you if you remembered oh okay now whoa
babe she's good now now she's all good you
could go right right because there's none
over there no i'm just a mere its a mere suggestion
you can drive no i can't drive because you
like to have a stick all 2000 oh this is like
a real car argument car argument? like we're
arguing about a car? like when two people
are driving and one is being a back seat driver
yeah oh yeah you're being a back seat driver
that's fun that's funny but this is a life
or death situation so yeah somebody said don't
ask for advice on the twitch stream who the
[ __ ] you think i am ninja? somebody said
ninja isn't the top streamer uh actually you
know it's actually funny you say that because
ninja isn't the top streamer anymore he's
still [ __ ] good right? oh nick mercs who
am I nick mercs aw thanks what'd she say she
said good job kristin that's sweet aw sweet
who a friend of mine wow okay well we're friends
now all right let's move it forward it's lit
now there we go oh look at the mushrooms that
GREW
whoa oh wow the mushrooms are beautiful they're
glowing in the dark i have a question for
the twitchers oh is that twitchers it's people's
twitch people on twitch in the chat twitchers
is racist how much would you guys pay to watch
him on mushrooms do mushrooms dude I can't
be bought I would pay everything in my savings
i can't be bought i can't be bought I can't
be bought 200k somebody says wow there's a
price for everything sweetheart honestly 50
billion
follow the green thing oh yeah you're close
just turn around you just this one walks into
walls with this video game come on you can
see where i am you know but do you see i'm
trying to go towards you and i'm just kind
of running into so keep going forward just
moving forward is always the thing I know
babe but there's stuff in the way no it's
all good but this is a video game so moving
forward is the thing but do you see i'm moving
forward but i'm going sideways that's fine
so keep exploring
aw chenny
just keep exploring
chenz
guys I'm sorry
whoa whoa cool whoa imagine my dad playing
this game he'd be like the [ __ ] i think
it'd be cute it would be cute he wouldn't
understand that no he'd laugh with that you
get swept up in it look he'd be doing the
Bill laugh thing
your dad really is just the best human on
the planet
boom shoot me out interstellar am i going
the right way if i go forward do you see me
i'm working on me here kind of well no it
takes two! i know but look i know it takes
two but oh yeah wow so hit x okay i don't
know whoa look at that thing
all right and because i stopped and helped
you hit x yeah you got to keep moving it up
there we go x when you hit it x when you hit
it and i'll just wait for you on my piece
but i don't know where i'm going well not
down okay hit the x and go up up up x yeah
okay there we go now get into that one yeah
dude when you get there hit x up in that one
dude now check this out where are we you might
want to brace yourself look try to get on
the being i'm on the being get on the being
look at that thing I would be [__] myself
dude we gotta go on vacation what about this
makes you see this and like if we were in
the water in Costa Rica and we were scuba
diving
nothing will happen here would be nice catfish
whoa this is gorgeous the same hieroglyphics
over and over again that's from the movie
Congo
i'm a film buff let's do some rapid fire questions
while we're here i don't you you just fell
off the fish you can't even do this game and
you want to do rapid fire questions you'll
die dude it's too hard what is your favorite
no fruit blueberry what i already told you
that before the stream started what was your
favorite subject in school i didn't have one
too dude [ __ ] all that lunch what's your
favorite color i don't want to do this purple
um what's your favorite thing about our son
oh man he's the best he is really well behaved
and very funny gets the joke dude and he also
i was bonking my head last night making him
laugh and today he woke up and started bonking
his head like he remembered but i could never
pick one favorite thing of our son because
everything about him is my favorite I know
he's so cool
somebody said lay off the claws what claws
white claws oh
because you're you're [ __ ] faced honestly
let's see how much i've had i've had a half
of a white claw that's your limit you're [ __
] face what if you went what if you stopped
drinking and you looked in the mirror and
you just had like mascara running down and
you were just like oh my god i'm really [ __
] up remember that video that when we were
first dating like a year into us dating and
you picked me up yeah that was the first time
you saw me drunk yes and it was hilarious
i still have that video i do is it bad to
put it up i don't give a [ __ ] it's hilarious
you're the funniest drunk ever but also I
was so drunk i did a joke about how you were
walking into the thing and looking in the
mirror and you just kind of i want you to
take it in and then you can talk about your
story take it in and you just kind of went
ha ha remember but take it in right take it
in it's all good but we gotta do this
somebody said chris wants to play and kristin
wants to talk lol yeah that's true that's
pretty much that's how it goes i don't do
these side games the video game side games
i don't do let's get on these though
that looks like a shooting range i don't want
to do it i want to play the whole game i want
to beat it is there just a talk part of twitch
whoa is this a game is there a tar a talk
part of twitch yeah it's called just chatting
babe where are you going just exploring how
do we just i want to get out of here and just
keep playing that well i figured it out did
i oh did i go backwards ms.backwards over
here dude
why do you do that what's going on it offends
me that you do that do i have bad senses of
where i am just go there straight nice you
see the blue thing right that's the thing
that i keep forgetting about well don't how
about this don't forget about it anymore oh
okay just go to the blue thing always because
i'm the blue thing you're the green thing
and i know that because whenever i'm lost
i look for it and i see it and then i go get
you oh so you're admitting that you get lost
too no great when i get when i lose you is
what i meant to say this is hard dude i can
already tell i'm not gonna like this one at
all why are there so many bees its a game
i know but there's so many when there weren't
any in the first two stages and now there's
so many change up the animals and insects
dude we fought a [ __ ] toolbox and a vacuum
that was fun as [ __ ] these bees are annoying
you could make a game oh uh my video game
would be so simple and so bad so bad but people
would honestly probably laud me for it people
would laud me for it
laud means like I know what laud means i can't
believe that you said it that people would
laud me if i make a video game? yes you don't
you don't you don't think that I would make
a good video game no you literally just said
i would make a video game and it would be
so bad so that people would get it and they
would laud me people like that it's like an
Eric Roberts movie i watch him you bring up
Eric Roberts an odd amount of times I wonder
why i bring him up because he's great i think
he's just such a perfect example of the kind
of guy that you like mhm he's attractive yep
he's a bad actor okay well he's in bad movies
all right baby but he thinks he's great okay
and that's your favorite kind of guy i can't
argue with like [ __ ] almost all of those
except for the bad actor dude that guy kills
it zap them up we sap them up dude let's set
them up dude they're coming close like they
know like they don't like like we don't know
to sap them up that's the [ __ ] ego on these
[ __ ] wow
babe do you know what projecting is
yeah you better project the [ __ ] sap out
of these bees before I come hey bees look
at this mind your [ __ ] beeswax it's cool
right when i say that right oh yeah very very
cool alright check it out hey bees I can't
bee-lieve you're trying that very cool right
oh my god i love these kinds of jokes i'm
an action movie guy you know do some more
um okay i'll do more we know there'll be more
bees you better bee-lieve it i i already used
that one but but did you yeah i used two that
was one of them you forget already and you
said you like it oh but do i have Alzheimers
somebody said what's sap-pening
that's funny oh should i do mine that i came
up with your what my one joke that i came
up with
they're so bad she has the worst
wait I have to remember it
you have one you don't remember it there's
two lines
oh dude there's a beetle a giant beetle i
knew about that because i i know a lot about
oh
what does a witch make her
babe it is not time for these kinds of jokes
what does a witch make her flu medicine in
okay you can say it now i know the answer
oh. a cold-ron
okay now back to killing this giant beetle
and also dude
it's pretty good
no that's bad
sap up the grates!
what's a grate
well think about what the word grate might
mean
oh my God
i don't mean to be mean but g-r-a-t-e!
wow i'm boycotting until you apologize
i'm sorry what did i do wrong
you said think about what grate might mean
like you're my kindergarten teacher
i'm trying not to tell you what to do that's
why
this is you trying not to tell me to do wow
i'm saying think about what grate means rather
than the [ __ ] grate! you understand what
i'm saying
this is the stuff
those are the two options that I have?
you say hold on a second the money that we're
gonna spend in therapy by the end of our lives
is going to somebody said remember your therapy
that's exactly what i'm doing you say you
say i say the grates and you say what is grate
and i say well let's think about what grate
means instead of the [ __ ] grates! use your
goddamn eyes! i would never say that
I would never say use your goddamn eyes and
you know that
You wouldn't say it to me but you would say
that to everyone else that you know
like a postmates driver?
you know something funny about chris that
i didn't know is that i was always really
nice to him the first year we were dating
can you get the grates while you tell the
story that's probably not true
sure
but is this something you like about me?
yeah all right well then
i didn't know that you um like your love language
is talking [ __ ]
yeah
and you like when I talk [ __ ] to you it's
like a [ __ ] yeah dude it makes you feel
what's the word
um i don't know uh heard? well okay well how
about this hear this
telling stories during the final bosses is
prohibited it's really hard to it's really
hard to hit these final bosses while you're
telling a story about our childhood or whatever
yeah but I do what I want though
okay i know you'll do what you want but PLEASE
sap the grates
whoa you do you know what dude you're doing
too much you're doing too much just relax
have a good time i put some lotion on oopsie
daisy dude one more sapping it up dude once
one more sapping it up oh dude he's doing
everything man oh you got those red rings
on oh that's okay dude i can dodge them and
i can jump oh [ __ ] but i'll tell you this
much oh here comes a red ring but we knew
about it yeah dude hey dude you're doing way
too much you work [ __ ] seven days a week
what about those weekend days huh you gotta
have some time to chill with your lady [ __
] babe bring him over here you gotta chill
with your lady boom oh no take a relax
I fell but it's fine dude
this guy doesn't even know what the [ __ ] just
hit him i hope this is the boss because oh
this is the boss i think i spoke too soon
let's go
if you lost your voice in a tragic accident
how would you get your points across your
angry points all the time
oh dude that's where the cult comes in for
real
what do you mean
they know what i want
this game's cool dude died died i don't like
it got her we opened her up she might not
be done-zo we probably gotta get her head
you pay for that again dude oh that this is
good you got to get her head i think i don't
even know no her heads oh the chain the chain
you gotta get the chain you got the [ __ ]
almost almost
ok the chain is sapped
so we just have to kill them and I get it
ok I gotta watch out there's sap on the chain
I understand
beautiful
wow she's probably like oh you shouldn't have
done that and then she comes back
we did it right okay that was good
we did it oh nice oh that fat bee helped us
i knew it was gonna be the cut scene too yeah
yeah we're done oh are we yeah we went for
an hour and a half no this is a cutscene oh
okay
wow look at that that's like the movie blown
away with kurt russell remember that movie
babe everyone remembers that movie he jumps
off the dock nice dude hell yeah man we did
it that's great we should stop there that's
a great stopping place let's end the twitch
stream with a compliment okay well you're
saying both compliment me
like you compliment me
i can go first i honestly am really impressed
with my thighs with my thighs lately the way
i've been working out and it's really they're
really it's really paying off
now you do one
no now you do me
okay um i will do you here we go you honestly
tried to give me your controller a few times
and i said no you do it and what you did it
because of your determination your prowess
your stead-fadness stead-fadness steadfastness
you're just intuitive yeah thank you you're
welcome and also props to me for realizing
that right oh yeah okay that's not your compliment
you've got to make your own compliment
yeah yeah I would say you're really working
on your anger and I'm proud of you for that
what the [ __ ] dude I mean you're like making
it so real
yeah. I'm not a comic
okay go ahead
and also you're handsome and I love you
wow thank you stead-fadness somebody said
stead-fadness
Someone said Chris pretty bad at the compliments
no way dude come on you're amazing dude you're
great
squirrels great guys we thought bees weren't
so bad
time to...ew!
all right thanks guys thanks for watching
wait all right we gotta finish let's finish
this cut scene and then we'll see what's up
you also have great thighs thank you to me
we're still live don't do anything crazy please
like what don't do your usual racial slurs
don't they're still watching don't they're
still watching don't tell them how Calvin's
a hologram do not they're still watching